قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف ان
الهدنه في كارباخ لم تحترم وان الاعلان
المشترك بين ارمينيا واذربيجان يؤكد على
مرجعيه مسار التفاوض وشكله من جانبها دع
ريفان لتشكيل اليه للتحقق من خرق الهدنه
في كارباخ بينما طالبت باكو باشراك انقره
في اي مفاوضات
للحل
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما هي فرص نجاح الجهود الساعيه الى
تثبيت اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في اقليم
كارباخ وما دلاله عدم الالتزام به حتى
الان وما هي انعكاسات تعثر الالتزام بوقف
اطلاق النار على محاولات اعاده المفاوضات
لتسويه ازمه الاقليم في اطار مجموعه
منسك
[موسيقى]
في مستهل مباحثات مع نظيره الارميني زهراب
مناس كيان في موسكو لبحث تطبيق وقف اطلاق
النار والتحضير لاعاده اطلاق المفاوضات في
اطار مجموعه منسك لحل ازمه كارباخ قال
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان وقف اطلاق النار
في الاقليم لم يتم احترامه لافروف الذي
كان قد اجرى اتصالا هاتفيا مع التركي في
اطار جهود احتواء القتال في كارباخ اكد ان
الاعلان المشترك بين باكو وفان يؤكد على
مرجعيه مسار التفاوض وشكله بينما واصل
طرفا القتال في الاقليم تبادل الاتهامات
بخرق اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار ووضع المزيد
من التصورات والشروط للحل في
كارباخ الاعلان المشترك يؤكد على مرجعيه
مسار التفاوض وشكله ومنظمه الامن التعاون
في اوروبا ومجموعه منسك تتالف من مجموعه
كبيره من الدول ولكن هذه الدول اوكلت
اداره مسار التفاوض والوساطه للدول الثلاث
اي روسيا والولايات المتحده
وفرنسا للاسف في الوقت الحالي لا نلاحظ اي
مؤشرات ايجابيه بالنسبه لوقف اطلاق النار
اذربيجان لا تحترم اتفاقات وقف اطلاق
النار واود هنا ان ابرز اهميه اليات
التحقق المتفق عليها والتي تمكن من تثبيت
هدنه قابله للبقاء ان تثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار هو ما سيسمح لنا بالتقدم فيما يخص
القضايا العالقه ارمينيا ستظل ملتزمه
بايجاد حل سلمي للصراع في
كارباخ لابد ان تشارك تركيا في ايجاد حل
لهذه القضيه وان تلعب دورا فعالا تساءلت
بعض وسائل الاعلام التركيه عن سبب تغييب
تركيا عن مفاوضات موسكو هذه ليست مرحله
تتدخل فيها كل الدول ذات العلاقه بالم
هذه مرحله تم اعلان وقف اطلاق النار فيها
لكن علينا انلا ننسى ان وقف اطلاق النار
هذا كان لاسباب انسانيه بحته لهذا لم تكن
هناك حاجه لتدخل كل الاطراف دول منسك
بعيده عن المنطقه وهي دول لا علاقه لها
بالموضوع ولم يؤتي تدخل هذه الدول باي
ثمره حتى الان منذ 30 عاما فمنذ نحو 30
عاما لم يتم تسليمنا سنتيمترا واحدا من
ارض اذربيجان عن طريق المفاوضات لماذا
اذا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
باكو احمد شهيدوف رئيس المعهد الاذربيجاني
للديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان وكذلك
معنا او ينضم
الينا معنا من يرفان سوس اتسان عضو في
البرلمان الارميني ومن مدينه كولونيا غرب
المانيا لؤي المدهون الصحفي المختص في
الشؤون الاوروبيه اهلا بكم جميعا وابدا
معك سييد احمد شاهي دوف وانت تحدثنا من
باكو وهناك الكثير من الجهود والحراك
الدبلوماسي اليوم على الصعيدين على سواء
مع وزير
الخارجيه الارميني والروسي او عفوا
الاذربيجاني والروسي وكذلك على مستوى
وزراء الدفاع في اي اطار ياتي هذا الحراك
الدبلوماسي اولا
ولماذا في يعني مع تركيا يجري هذا الحوار
وليس مع
باكو بدايه اريد ان اذكر ان اذربيجان
تتواجه مع ارهاب الارميني وكما حصل في
التسعينات عند مجزره
كجول حيث كان هنالك مقتل اكثر من 600 شخص
من المدنيين البريئين وال القوات
الارمينيه تستمر بقصفها الشديد على
الاراضي والمناطق السكنيه الاذربيجانيه
وهو خرق خطير
للهدنه
انسانيه واليوم امس حوالي الساعه الثانيه
صباحا استهدفت صواريخ مناطق سكنيه في
منطقه كنجه وكجزء من ذلك كان هنالك
ايضا خرق ل وقف الاطلاق النار الذي تم
توصل اليه في موسكو
و كان هنالك استهداف واضح من ارمينيا
للمناطق السكنيه في اذربيجان لذلك استجابه
لهذه الاستفزازات الارمينيه فان اذربيجان
اطلقت عمليه عسكريه واسعه النطاق ضد هذا
الارهاب
الارميني والذي هو متركز في ناغورني
كارباخ ومناطق
اخرى بالنسبه
ل الحسم السياسي والسلمي لهذا الصراع لا
اعتقد ان هنالك امكانيه لايجاد نهايه لهذا
الصراع بطريقه سلميه لانه بعد هذه بعد
التوصل الى
وقف الاطلاق النار عام
1994 وخلال هذه السنوات 28 الماضيه كانت
اذربيجان تدعم السلام والمفاوضات السلميه
وعلى
كل عبر كل
المواقع الدوليه والمنظمات والي حاولت ان
تضغط على الجانب الارميني من اجل الاحترام
قرارات مجلس الامن الذي يطالب
بالانسحاب الفوري لكل القوات المحتله في
ناغورنو كارباغ والمناطق المحيطه بها لسوء
الحظ خلال السنوات ال8 الماضيه لم يتمكن
المجتمع الدولي من الضغط على ارمينيا من
اجل سحب قواتها من الاراضي
الاذربيجانيه في مقابل ما كل ما ذكرت
اتحول اليك سيد لؤي المدهون في في برلين
يعني كان المفترض ان يعني يكون هناك وقف
لاطلاق النار والتزام بهذه الهدنه التي
اعلنت منتصف السبت الماضي ماذا يعني عدم
التزام الطرفين بها حتى هذه الساعه وما
فرص الالتزام بها
مجددا نعم اعتقد ان عدم التزام الطرفين
بهذه الهدنه ان دل على شيء فانما يدل على
ان الوقت ليس الان مناسب وليس ناضج من
وجهه نظر طرفي النزاع خاصه الطرف الاذري
الاذربيجاني فيما يتعلق الان بفرض او
بالالتزام بهذه الهده لماذا لان اذربيجان
تريد تغيير الحقائق على الارض ما نح
نلاحظه الان في هذا الصراع ان هذا الصراع
الذي تم تجميده لاكثر من 30 عاما الان عاد
الى الواجهه نظرا لان الحكومه الاذريه على
قناعه تامه بان عليها العمل على تغيير
الامر على الواقع لماذا لان الجهود
الدبلوماسيه فيما يتعلق بمجموعه منسك
وتطبيق قرارات الامم المتحده لم تؤتي في
لم تغير شيئا على ارض الواقع وما الذي
تغير في في هذه الجوله من من التصعيد تغير
هو الحضور التركي تركيا الان دخلت بثقلها
العسكري والاقتصادي والسياسي وتؤيد بشكل
كامل غير مشروط الحكومه الاذريه وايضا
تغير في الموقف الروسي الموقف الروسي الان
يريد اعطاء الحكومه الاذريه عده ايام او
اسابيع من اجل تحقيق تغيير في الوضع على
الارض حتى يتم ح حاله الامور اعتقد انه
ليس في مصلحه الحكومه الاذريه عفوا عفوا
يعني تعليقا على ما ذكرت تقول بان هذه
يعني التزام بهذه الهدنه لا يمكن ان ان
يكون بسبب ان اذربيجان تريد تغيير الوقائع
على الارض لكن هناك تصريح ايضا لعلف
الرئيس الاذربيجاني يقول بان هذه الهدنه
يجب ان لا ننسى بانها فقط لاسباب انسانيه
بحته الى مدى يقلل من شان هذه الهدنه
لتهدئه الاوضاع
وتهيئه الاوضاع
لتوجه نحو مفاوضات
حقيقيه السيد
لؤي اذا يبدو انه انضم الينا الان من
يرفان سوس افسان وهو العضو في البرلمان
الارميني ونبدا سيد اتيان بذا الاجتماع
بين وزير الخارجيه الروسي ونظيره الارميني
الذي كان من المفترض ومن المقرر ان يستغرق
ساعه وانما استغرق ثلاث ساعات ما هو تفسير
ذلك الى اي مدى يمكن ان يفهم على اتساع
الهدنه في الرؤى بين روسيا
وارمينيا شكرا على الاستضافه ان اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار الذي كان لاغراض
انسانيه والذي تم التوصل اليه في روسيا
قبل عده ايام وكان لم قد التقى وزير
خارجيتنا مع وزير خارجيه روسيا لان
اذربيجان لم تحترم وقف اطلاق هذا النار
حتى لاسباب
انسانيه لن نتمكن من مثلا الحصول على جثث
القتلى ولم يستعيد جت قتلاهم المشكله ان
اذربيجان
لديها برعايه تركيا الكثير من المرتزقه
والارهابيين وهم غير مهتمين باي حال من
الاحوال بالابقاء على وقف اطلاق النار
الانساني هدفهم واضح هو القضاء على سكان
ناغورنو كارباغ وارتكاب
مجازر
وايضا اجبارهم اما على ان يقتلوهم او ان
يغادروا المنطقه لذلك نحن مهتمون دائما
بوقف اطلاق
والاض لكن اذربيجان وتركيا ليست كذلك
والمشكله اعتقد ن توجه الاتهام لاذربيجان
التي لم تلتزم بوقف النار السيد افد سيان
تتحدثون عن خروقات من قبل اذربيجان لكن
يبدو ان موسكو لا تشارككم نفس وجهه النظر
هذا بدليل ان سيرجي لافروف عندما تحدث عن
هذه الخروقات واستياء روسيا منها لم يحمل
جهه بعينها هذه المسؤوليه الا يبدو بانكم
ايضا مدانون في هذه المساله بنفس القدر
الذي فيه مدان
اذربيجان ان هذا هذه المقارنه غير مضحكه
للغايه في حقيقه الامر لم يسمي رئيس وزراء
خارجيه روسيا بالاسماء
لكنها لكن ضمن مجموعه منسك هم لن يذكروا
او يلوموا الدول باسما لكن علينا ان نفكر
بشكل منطقي لماذا الجانب الارميني الذي
يتمكن من الذي يتكون من 3 ملايين شخص
سيكون مهتما بخرق لوقف لاطلاق النار مع
هنالك مقابل بلد يتوجه مع بلد يفوقه سكانا
ويحظى بدعم تركي هل بامكاننا ان نفسر هذا
الامر
وكل مسؤول اذربيجاني وممثل حكومي هم لا
يخفوا حقيقه انهم يستمرون بالاعمال
العدائيه والقتاليه هناك سيد احمد شهيدوف
عندما
يقول الهام عليف بان يجب على العالم ان لا
ينسى بان هذه الهدنه هي او هذا وقف اطلاق
النار هذا الاتفاق تم فقط لاسباب انسانيه
بحته كيف يمكن تفسير هذا التصريح اولا كيف
يمكن ان
نفهمه
اريد ان اذكر زميلي في ارمينيا الصوت
يتقطع من
المصدر وحمله الاعلاميه ضد اذربيجان ليس
هنالك اي
دليل حول وجود اي مرتزقه في ناغورني
كارباخ هذه المعلومات المظلله والاخبار
الزائفه تحرص ارمينيا على نشرها لان هنالك
تقطع في
الصوت طيب على ما يبدو هناك خلل في وصول
الصوت الينا سوف نعمل على اصلاحه ونعود لك
سيد احمد شاهي دوف اتحول اليك سيد سوس افت
ستيان ارمينيا في اطار هذه الهدنه واتفاق
وقف النار تحدثت عبر وزير خارجيتها طالبت
باليه لوقف هذه الخروقات
والتحقق من
ما طبيعه الاليه التي تطالب بها ارمينيا
الان وما مدى واقعيتها اذا كانت هذه
الهدنه مجرد لاسباب انسانيه
اعلنت اعتقد ان باستطاعتنا ان نحظى بوقف
اطلاق النار لاغراض انسانيه ويجب ان يكون
تكون كل الاطراف مهتمه بهذا الامر يجب ان
يكون هنالك بيئه مناسبه
معرفه ما يحدث لكن
اذربيجان مدعومه بتركيا ببساطه ليست مهتمه
بهذا الامر قالوا ان هذا هذه فقط هدنه
انسانيه كما قلت هم لا يهتمون لقد قاموا
باستئجار المرتزقه من سوريا من اجل ان
يستخدموه في حقيقه الامر الامر واضح وهم
يستغلهم ويستفيدون منهم والجانب
الارميني هم وارمينيا وسكان
لي متين بخق اطلاق لقد را
كنائس
السيدان من حيث عدد سكان سكان اذربيجان هي
ثلاثه اضعاف عدد سكان فما الحاجه ل
استعانه اذربيجان بهؤلاء المرتزقه
يعني اعتقد ان هذه افضل طريقه
لاخفاء خسائرهم لذلك لانه لا
يمكن لن يجبروا على رفع اي تقارير لذلك
الهام عليف يخفي كل المعلومات عن ساحات
المعركه وهذا الامر مناسب لهم والامر ليس
فقط الهام عليف بل تم استئجاره من تركيا
من قبل تركيا ومن سوريا ونقلهم اذاك
وهنالك اخبار من الجارديان ونيويورك تايمز
تقارير موثقه
وصور لهؤلاء لهؤلاء المرتزقه واعتقدوا ان
هذا الامر ربما يتسم ببعض الدهاء لكن
استخدام مرتزقه نحن نعيش في القرن ال 21 و
لن يتمكنوا من اخفاء
المعلومات اذا عاد معنا السيد احمد شهيدوف
وتعليقك السيد احمد شهيدوف على ما قاله
السيد
اتيان
اعتقد ان زميلي من ارمينيا مره اخرى يكرر
هذه الاخبار الزائفه حول المرتزقه
وهم لا يريدون ان يتقبلوا فكره قوه الجيش
الاذربيجاني
وايضا العمليات العسكريه وان يعترفوا
بهزيمتهم لذلك عن طريق نشرهم لهذه الاخ
الزائفه يريدون ان يقحموا دولا
اخرى مثل روسيا والاتحاد الاوروبي لكي
يساعدوهم وايضا
يدعون المجتمع الدولي ان لا يظل غير مبالي
لما يحدث لانه ب بعد الاتفاق الذي تم
التوصل اليه في موسكو وبعد ساعات من هذا
الاتفاق فان القوات الارمينيه العسكريه
اطلقت الصواريخ على الى مدينه جنجه
وخلال هذا القاصف قتل العديد من الاشخاص
هنالك تقطع في الصوت وهنالك مره اخرى
اظهرت الطبيعه هذا الامر الطبيعه
الارهابيه
للسلطات الارمينيه واعتقدوا ان كل
المنظمات
الدوليه عليها ان
تس اذا في ظل هذا سوف نعود لك سيد احمد
شهيدوف تعثر الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار في
كارباخ يثير الكثير من التساؤلات بشان
اراده طرفي القتال في التوصل الى حل
متفاوض عليه لمشكله الاقليم اذا يعود معنا
السيد لؤي المدهون صحفي المختص في الشؤون
الاوروبيه
هو عبر الهاتف من من برلين يعني سيد لؤي
المدهون ما مدى واقعيه هذه الدعوات للتوجه
الان بشكل فوري كما تدعو موسكو والاتحاد
الاوروبي معها لطاوله ال المفاوضات
اي للتفاوض على تسويه جوهريه ودون شروط
مسبقه في ظل هذا عدم الالتزام بدنه على
الارض لا اعتقد ان هذه التوقعات لها ارضيه
واقعيه لماذا لان الدور الروسي ايضا دور
مزدوج روسيا لها علاقات جيده وهي تلتزم
بتحالف دفاعي مع ارمينيا لكنها لا تريد ان
تقحم نفسها داخل هذا الصراع بشكل يجبرها
على الدخول في مواجهه مع ارمينيا مع تركيا
بشكل مباشر وايضا علاقاتها جيده مع مع مع
اذربيجان وهي تزود الطرفي طرفي النزاع
بالاسلحه ولكنها تزود اذربيجان باسلحه
اكثر تطورا من من ارمينيا هي معنيه ب
بتغيير الا واعتقد ان تركيا ايضا اعطت
ضوءا اخضر لتركيا للدخول على خط على
النزاع لا اعتقد ان هذا التصعيد جاء مفاجا
نحن عايشنا مناورات عسكريه تركيه في شهر
اغسطس الماضي اعتقد ان روسيا ستسمح
لارمينيا بتغيير بعض الوقائع على الارض
حتى يتم تغيير المسار التفاوضي الوضع
التفاوضي اعتقد ان الحكومه الارم
الارمينيه الاذريه عفوا مصممه في خلال هذه
الجوله على تغيير الوضع التفاوضي لانها
غير مستعده للانتظار سنوات
طويله حتى يقوم المجتمع الدولي باساليب
دبلوماسيه لفرض او قرارات المجلس الامن
الدولي لان وفق القانون الدولي والقرارات
الامم المتحده
الاقليم ناغورني كارباخ منطقه محتله ولكن
في السنوات الاخيره الحكومه الارمينيه
قامت باجراءات لدمج هذا الاقليم بشكل كلي
داخل داخل الدوله الارمينيه لكن الان في
هذا الوضع تغير الحكومه الارمينيه الان في
وضع في وضع معزول نوعا ما هي تعاني من
ضغوط الحكومه الروسيه تريد اعطاء الجانب
الاذري فسحه من الوقت مده من الوقت ربما
اسبوع او اسبوعين لتغيير هذه الوقائع خاصه
في ظل الزخم الذي جاء مع دخول تركيا على
هذا الخط من اجل الدخول في مفاوضات حقيقيه
نحتاج الى تغيير بعض الوقائع حتى يتم
التمهيد لعقد صفقه اقليميه برعايه روسيا
وتركيا وهذه الصفقه يمكن لا يمكن يعني
يمكن ان تؤدي في النهايه الى استعاده
اذربيجان لبعض من اراضيها المحتله من من
ارمينيا هل هي في اطار مجموعه مسك ما
تتحدث عن هذه الصفقه التركيه الروسيه هل
يمكن ان تكون في اطار يعني ايضا بالتوافق
مع هذه المج مموعه والتي تصر اذربيجان
الان في اطار يعني تصريحات عليف اليوم بان
تكون تركيا ايضا مشاركه
فيها نعم هذه النقطه نحن نتحدث عن مجموعه
منسك وهي الهيئه الدوليه التي كلفها التي
المجتمع الدولي في قبل 30 عاما باداره هذا
النزاع المجمد لكن هذه الهيئه في الواقع
هي الان تتكون فقط من روسيا حضور فرنسا
وحضور الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حضور
وهمي غير موجود على ارض الواقع تيا
تاريخيا نعم مظله مظله فرنسا الولايات
المتحده وروسيا كذلك هي تمثل ايضا نوعا من
الشرعيه الشرعيه الدوليه الدبلوماسيه
الدول ولكن ما ما هي قدراتها على تغيير
على التاثير على طرفي النزاع هذا السؤال
المهم اعتقد ان الحكومه الاذربيجانيه وانا
احلل عن بعد ولا يعني بناء على معطيات
واضحه هنا والمعطيات الواضحه تقول ان
الحكومه الاذربيجانيه تريد استغلال الزخم
التركي والحضور التركي ومن اجل الضغوط او
طلب دخول ترك والمشاركه تركيا او ادماج
تركيا في مجموعه مسك بجانب روسيا يعني اذا
في نهايه
هذه هذه المفاوضات والاشكاليات والتراشق
سيحدث اتفاق نوع القضيه ادمتها الوقد الان
لا اعتقد انه يعني ناضج لتحقيق ارضيه
لمفاوضات جديده تمهد لحل هذا الصراع نحن
نتحدث
عناني يع يعاني من المبالاه مبالاه لام
مبالاه و لا مبالاه لكن في ضوء هذه
اللامبالاه لا الطرفان مازال يتحدثان عن
العوده الى المفاوضات يعني ان كانت
تصريحات على يف او تصريحات ارمينيا التي
تقول لا بديل ل المفاوضات لاجال الحل
للتسويه وهنا اتحدث اليك سيد سوس اتيان
يعني الرئيس عليف قال بان اذربيجان لا
تنتظر يعني تواريخ محدده لانسحاب ارمينيا
من الاقليم المتنازع عليه هل يمكن ان يكون
ذلك مشجعا لعوده ارمينيا لهذه مفاوضات ل
التشاور من الواضح انه ليس بمؤشر جيد
عندما تقوم باستخدام الارهابين و تحضرهم
من تركيا كدعم لك ليس جيدا وعندما تقتل
المدنيين الامر ليس جيد ولا حتى يقربون من
التفكير بحل لكن ما هو مهم الان ان على
المجتمع الدولي ان يضغط على اذربيجان ان
يعود الى وقف الاطلاق النار الانساني
واعتقد انه وصلنا الى مرحله في الصراع
فقط جمهوريه ناغورنو
كارباخ من اجل ان نمنع اباده نعم لكن
سؤالي سيد اان يعني ما هو موقف ارمينيا من
هذا التصريح لعل
ياذ
اوكي للغايه ان استهداف المدنيين لن
يساعدنا في الوصول الى حل يجب ان يكون
هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار وبعد ذلك يمكن
اجراء المحادثات الامر واضح للغايه لكن
اذربيجان ليست مهتمه بتحقيق ذلك هي تريد
مع تركيا ان تبيد الناس في ناغورني كارباغ
والطريقه الوحيده هو اعتراف الدوليه
بجمهوريه ناغورني كارباغ ولن امل من ترديد
هذا الامر لان يجب هزيمه غرضهم السياسي
وغرضهم السياسي هو تغيير وقاع على الارض ا
اع لك السيد احمد شهيدوف يعني على ماذا
تعول اذربيجان ليس هناك وقف لاطلاق النار
على ماذا يتحدث عن العوده الى المفاوضات
لكن يقول لا تسويه دون العوده او تحرير كل
الاراضي ولا تسويه ما ما ما لا نحققه في
السياسه سوف نحققه على الارض على ماذا
تعول بدايه ان الشروط المسبقه والموقف
الرسمي لاذربيجان ان يرفان عليها ان توقف
التدخل
الدولي ويجب ان يتم ايقاف احتلال ناغورني
كارباخ والاراضي المحيطه بها
لكن اظهار عدم الاحترام للاتفاق الذي تم
التوصل اليه بوسطه روسيه
و امر غير مقبول و سيكون هنالك نتائج
مدمره على ارمينيا نحن ندين هذه
الاعتداءات من ارمينيا وندعو المجتمع
الدولي لاتخاذ خطوات حاسمه
لوقف العدائيه من ارمينيا وزميلي من
ارمينيا ما سماه بالاعتراف بجمهوريه
ناغورني كارباخ لكن ليس هنالك اي بلد في
العالم يعترف بما هذذه الدوله شكرا لك سيد
احمد شدوف رئيس المعهد الاذربيجاني
للديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان كنت معنا من
باكو اشكرك منير فانسو اتسان عضو البرلمان
الارميني وكان معنا من كولونيا لؤي
المدهون الصحفي المختص في الشؤون
الاوروبيه شكرا جزيلا لكم وعلى المتاب
مشاهدينا الكرام نصل بكم الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر
جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء